you guys know about the Middle East it's
like middle earth but more violent so
Hamas which is in charge of the Gaza
Strip they were going to have a little
peace thing the Israelis and the
Palestinians were going to get together
send 37 kids from Gaza to Israel to the
west bank they were going to go to a zoo
I think in Jerusalem and it was just
going to be a little thing for kids to
get together and talk and see other
people etc etc of course Hamas not that
into it we've got a quote from their
spokesman Hamas spokesman a odd bazoom
said the decision was made to protect
the culture of our children and our
people from normalizing relations with
Israel he said Hamas would make sure a
trip will never happen again all right
so I don't want to get into a big debate
about the Middle East let's not do that
right this second but what I thought was
interesting about this is first of it
doesn't these type of stories don't get
much play we only talk about it when
there's bombing and things like that but
isn't this kind of stuff more important
because all the leaders now are going to
die off eventually right 20 30 years
they're all going to be gone it's the
next generation that has to have some
feeling of peace so if we can't even get
kids to go to a zoo together I guess my
question is is the Middle East just
perpetually screwed well I want to say
thank you for bringing up this topic
because my one of my new year's
resolutions for 2014 was to solve the
israeli-palestinian crisis and december
31st so I gotta get to it let's get to
UM and I think no I you know in some
ways I think this is encouraging because
they're even doing this oh but you're
not doing well no there's the effort to
attempt to do it and that if initially
there was approval from whoever there
the neo from Hamas to allow this happen
and then it got rejected when they're
the day of it so what I think that
points out to me is something the most
people don't acknowledge about Hamas
which is that like any political party
there are more moderate elements and I
mean we like to think of home house we
think they're all just death Israel you
know that's just the there they all have
that you know tattooed on their arm
swing but like any political part is
that there is there are modern more
moderates and there you know there is a
there some who obviously when this was
initially approved we thought this was a
good idea they lost this battle but at
least it indicates that there are people
within Hamas or in the west by mean in
Gaza who want to promote p person a
person connections
I mean the people of the children of
Gaza and children of Israel so while
this one it's disappointing oh and and
you know sort of plays into the idea
that Hamas is totally unwilling to even
do the most moderate thing at oil which
is let kids go to go to a zoo I think
that this is your right is what's going
to have to happen it is going to the
next generation and if unfortunately if
the hardliners win then these things
don't happen but if more moderate
elements can be encouraged and promoted
on both sides but that's okay I think
that's the important part that the both
sides part so you know i I've read that
younger Israelis are more hardline than
out of their parents are and that's
largely because they grew up with this
complete divide where they didn't have
any interaction with the other side was
older generation even though they were
fighting for much of the past 20 30 40
years they did have some normalize
relations and they realize they're not
all so bad and there can be a better way
whereas if you grow up only seeing them
as enemies and and never having any
normal interactions with them you harden
your stance so I think these kind of
trips are are very important but I think
that not just Hamas kids I mean I'm
Palestinians children should go to
Israel and see that people in Israel are
totally fine and normal and they're not
evil people that we need to kill and
throw into the ocean I think Israeli
children should go to hum to Gaza and
see how the Palestinians live and
realize wow they are living under some
really really bad conditions this isn't
right we need to fix this too right baby
killed or kidnapped if they went i guess
i get i get we write my findings like a
philosophic we have clearance which
parent volunteer for that one right like
you're not gonna send your kid and they
they're what they were there and you
know anything so I but I get your the
over right right right Notre massive
logistical realities I have you worked
out you want to send one kid in a
bulletproof bubble and have them float
over the place I guess I'm Seinfeld
bubbled a sentiment yeah but yeah I I do
think that the
any kind of real long-term solution to
any kind of situation like that has to
be with with with the younger generation
completely seeing and wanting that
change and accepting embracing it and
end at some point struggling for that
right so totally on board that part of
it so shouldn't this be the type of
thing you know they're signing all these
papers the UN thing just yesterday got
defeated at the Security Council their
Palestinians are going to icc they all
these paint it's just a lot of paperwork
and adults fighting about [ __ ] but
shouldn't this be the type of thing that
people actually rally around like that
to me like this is so basic like and if
they can't even do this the idea that
they call it a peace process is really
just because both words have a letter P
in it right but if they can't get kids
together then what real hope is there
but yeah what's the glimmer of hope that
you can take look so so I mean as
Malcolm correctly pointed out this trip
was at some point approved by Hamas and
for whatever reasons day on approved or
disapproved it and and look III don't
understand the motivations behind it and
you know I would love to get someone
from Hamas explain why they think cast
this is a good idea i get a lot yeah
yeah and they don't they would argue
that it's a propaganda you know that's
you know yeah of course maybe it is i
don't i don't know okay so for whatever
reason they decide to not do it but I'm
a little reluctant to just isolate one
incident and cast blame on one side or
the other because this situation has so
many layers yes so much history and so
many instances were each side can
rightfully claim that they were victims
of massive injustice that there's often
overreaction alright so it gets really
really didn't want to make a segment
about the whole freaking thing this was
really just like about kids and if we
can't get these freaking kids together
then I don't know what what hope we have
but you know who so you want just
another another note of optimism for the
new year you that's why you wanted to
cover this
you